لم يكن هذا العام كبقيه الاعوام عاما من
المعاناه فقد فيه الاوكرانيون حياتهم التي
كانوا يعرفونها وتحول فيه الى شعب من
المقاتلين منهم من في الثقور على جبهات
القتال واخرون على جبهات الحياه لضمان عدم
انهيار دولتهم وصمودها في وجه الروس
والبقيه يجاهدون باضعف الايمان الصبر على
اوضاع الانسانيه كارثه
بسبب الحرب ولن نستطيع ان نعيد ما فقدناهم
لكننا تعلمنا ان نعيش بشكل مختلف
توقع كيف العامه وقد فقدت الاسر
الاوكرانيه مئات الالاف من ابنائها اما
قتلى او جرحى او اسرى والملايين نازحون في
ارجاء الارض وقدمرت الحرب البنيه التحتيه
للدوله والغيت جميع مظاهر الاحتفالات براس
السنه الميلاديه من زينه او حفلات عامه
كما شددت السلطات على الالتزام بمواعيد
حضر التجوال الذي يبدا قبل منتصف الليل
بساعه مما يجبر المواطنين على استقبال
العام الجديد في بيوتهم
بالتاكيد نستقبل العام الجديد بامل
الانتصار سيكون عام 2023 عام النصر
الاوكرانيا حتما اشهر ان هذا العام سيكون
عام العمل الكبير لنا وللشعبنا وبلادنا
ونحن حتما سننتصر وبلادنا ستصبح اكثر حريه
وافضل وسنكون فيها سعداء
لا ان يكون هذا العام افضل
لله اننا مازلنا احياء
بالعام الجديد
على انهائها لصالح شعبها في ساحه القتال
او عن طريق قمه للسلام وفق شروطها ليتفرغ
الجميع لاعاده بناء ما دمرته الحرب وهو
دمار هائل وعوده ملايين النازحين من
النساء والاطفال ولم شمل شتات الاسر
الاوكرانيه حذيفه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
هي